[Musik]
bisher war von abos wird aber
konfrontation mit entega und babin
wollen heiraten was wiederum andere
verhindern wollen
und so fragt sich frei nach shakespeare
ob der liebe leichte schwingen das paar
zum ziel getragen werden
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
vor
er sei 27 und physiotherapeut schrieb
mir button zu rentieren vor einem jahr
rea und er seien das glücklichste paar
der welt wären da nicht leute und damit
war meine neugier geweckt wären da nicht
leute die schlecht über sie reden würden
dabei stammt er doch aus einer familie
in der anstand und respekt hochgehalten
würden sein vater habe ihn stets zur
ehrlichkeit und tugendhaftigkeit erzogen
und stets habe sein vater ihn gut
beraten die bruch muss damit man im ruf
steht mit kommissar facebook fcl
trezeguet zu lang sieht wohl durch hitze
und liberale die liberal wo dann mit dem
zertifikat ältere generation wo man von
friedrich langes dankte aber der
dominikus böhm autos sie heißt es auch
wir ab passt aber nicht bei anderen
unterschieden sind dankbar war bis nach
malaga bin so rentieren und seine
familie gehören zu den rund 40.000
tamilen in der schweiz
diese gelten inzwischen als
mustergültige migranten allerdings
bilden sie eine eigene gut vernetzte
gemeinschaft und bleiben meist unter
sich
es herrscht eine ausgeprägte soziale
kontrolle
jeder weiß über den anderen alles
[Applaus]
dieses hat schon dass mich großfamilie
möglichen kooperation machen wie der
kranken vor stocker toni kroos england
hat dann vor in der familie zusammen
das ist wunsch von mir rabin ist in der
schweiz geboren hat in bayern ein
gymnasium besucht und studiert obwohl er
wie viele andere junge männer lebt
trägen ihnen diese moralischen
verpflichtungen gegenüber den eigenen
eltern aber auch gegenüber den eltern
seiner freundin
ich hoffe dass religion nicht enthalten
dank der so etwas je mehr haut wirklich
als neue aktionäre und bereichert werde
etwas tochter glücklich wird rea garvey
arbeitet als konditorin die 23 jährige
besucht zusammen mit ihrer familie
regelmäßig die freie evangelische kirche
der tamilen in bayern dass ihr glaube an
gott in einem widerspruch zu ihrer liebe
stehen könnte
daran hätte sie nicht im traum gedacht
wenn sie fragt man sich das grobe er
stand dreas befürchtungen waren umsonst
zwar schluckten die eltern kurz leer
fügten sich abermals den wünschen ihrer
tochter etwas in der tamilischen
gemeinschaft keine
selbstverständlichkeit ist
es geht weiter runter aber zum beispiel
treu gemacht
wenn du jetzt darüber also ich hoffe
dass auch mache selbst mutter und sie
glaube dass natürlich zum beispiel der
vcb hatte da war mit cross motorrad hat
und sie könnte für uns einfacher wenn
ihre tochter bekomme dann darf sich auch
drahtlos erlebt doch allzu schrankenlos
dafür ihr glück vorerst nicht genießen
öffentliches turteln küssen und
dergleichen kommen nicht in frage
wie lange wird das jetzt noch so sieht
also in nicht öffentlicher also jetzt
wenn man es auch vorläufig 4 mache nach
damp dafür mit dem oberlauf handlicher
wird es sie nützen aber vorteil muss mir
versteckt sie es einfach nehmen
mitbekommt und seine wohnung
das ist erst wenn ich mich erst auf dem
dafür mit dem zimmer wohnung vorteil
dass etwas schrecklich geburtstag
prominenter aber streng gläubig sie
dafür dass sie immer noch würden mehr
als die hälfte aller tamilischen
hochzeiten von den eltern arrangiert
werden auch in ihrem umfeld komme dass
vor
und das in der schweiz im jahre 2016
es gab viel mit neuer kollege mit am
altar wo recht für versprochen worden
dass im gloria versprechen es geht doch
oliver sabine torregen entschleunigen
der frau so lange hier der haut und
schleimhaut also geht doch etwas andere
gebäude tv hier lehrt machte er das
super soft und da habe es für die
invasion suche sie was sie denkt er habe
jetzt wieder hochzeit ja immer versucht
mein vater hat ein pariser frau dort
davor meine ex-frau wie andrea sawatzki
ja oder nein das kann man sagen wenn er
oder sie nicht sagte er muss das machen
sie daraus doch jetzt ist das ja fiel
kritisch aus
es sind nicht die eltern die sich gegen
die hochzeit stellen und der widerstand
geht auch nicht auf die konflikte
zwischen den ethnien im heimatland
zurück es ist einzig die gemeinschaft
der christlichen freikirche die druck
auf das brautpaar ausübt
schwierigkeiten leider von friedrich
schiller
[Musik]
ja es wird lacht über uns gerettet oder
hat ebit des landtags sowie andere
religion zuhörern seine religion war bei
den zukünftigen schwiegereltern nur
kurze zeit ein thema dass eltern kamen
in den 80er jahren in die schweiz als in
sri lanka der bürgerkrieg tobte auch sie
haben sich den schweizer begebenheiten
so gut wie möglich angepasst und mittel
achten stock und sie haben schon gewusst
dass heiraten werden die eltern haben
uns verheiratet
ja so einfach war das die eltern haben
uns füreinander ausgesucht auch mutter
uta kumari und vater dampier awi bekamen
den unmut der eigenen kirche zu spüren
vor allem der pastor gab sich
unversöhnlich reha sagt christina binder
hindu hat er gesagt
da könne man nicht zusammenleben
da wolle er keine hochzeit machen bei
dem gottesdienst heißt es immer wir
sollten leute bringen ihr leben über 40
tausend tamilen immer heißt es bringen
bringen bringen
wir müssen die bekehren ihnen das wort
und leben jesu verkünden
es ist doch gut wenn wir einen mann
heiraten den sie dann zum christlichen
glauben fühlt das ist doch gut
oder warum sagen sie denn im training
bringen
fototermin in der kleinen wohnungen der
familie so rentieren in bern
es ist der morgen vor der zivilen
trauung sind sie stolz auf ihn hat er
die richtige gefunden hat er das gut
gemacht
sie sind auch zufrieden naja lingam und
navis vary so rentieren folgt in ihrem
herzen als sohn kabinen eröffnete dass
er ja gern zur frau haben wolle würde
dies aber typisch was bedeutet die wir
haben sind die vor allem aber für ältere
sehr wichtig das muss auch gemacht und
darum was ist aber wir wollen dich will
ich kann aber keine genauen grund kann
ich gar nicht sagen wie sie das
meisterhaft und 2006 das ist ja nicht
ganz klar aber es gibt irgendwie gebaut
oder vertragsfreiheit vorteil dass man
ihr richtiger wäre die tradition der
eigenen kultur zu respektieren und zu
ehren und gleichzeitig einen modernen
westeuropäischen alltag zu leben es ist
kein leichtes was berlin und viele in
seiner generation versuchen müssen
sind sie glücklich
die standesamtliche trauung ist für rea
und bat ihn der erste lang ersehnte
schritt in ein eigenständiges leben noch
immer wohnen beide bei ihren eltern auf
dem schloss waldeck in solothurn werden
sie hinter verschlossenen türen aber vor
den augen der engsten verwandten ja
zueinander sagen auch wenn sie mit dem
ja wort nicht alle zwänge auf einen
schlag ablegen können
aber wenn man vorher hatte biss und
kunst heißt so nach einer ecke respekt
[Gelächter]
setz mittel ist wird man tolerant ist
kein netz die deine augen klar keine
norm das war dann das ist mir vor wie es
läuft
alles scheint an diesem tag perfekt
rea und bat ihn haben eine weitere hürde
genommen
erstaunlicherweise ist selbst der pastor
der tamilischen glaubensgemeinschaft an
diesen großen tag anwesend
der mann also der sich vehement gegen
diese hochzeit gestellt hat heute
gratuliert er dem paar als ob nichts
wäre nur aufs gruppenfoto verzichtet er
und auch mündliche und schriftliche
interviewanfragen ignoriert er
wenigstens an diesem tag lässt sich das
paar jedoch nichts anmerken und genießt
sein neues stück freiheit
ein paar wochen später im wohnzimmer der
familie rawi erledigen die zwei familien
des paares die letzten vorbereitungen
für ein schönes hochzeitsfest doch die
vorfreude wird immer noch getrübt durch
die unstimmigkeiten welche von der
kirchlichen gemeinschaft ausgehen
der pastor hatte den bräutigam klar
gemacht dass nur das konvertieren vom
hinduismus hin zum christentum den weg
für eine ebnen würde
gegenüber gott dafür wird mit melasse
damit die sehr besonderes programm
kennenlernen der hertha regel
versicherung tageblatt erwartungen
zwischen der zivilen und der kirchlichen
trauung sind die negativen stimmen nicht
etwa verstummt beschimpfungen und
drohungen gegen reha haben in den
letzten tagen sogar noch zugenommen
hier hängt das fahrwerk ist und mehrere
telefonberater und herstellung ist auch
das stimmt gar nicht vorstellen
bewusst wird es stimme dass er aber
nicht so extrem
geld das sie zu jeder zeit jahres macht
die tochter das irgendwo und irgendwie
nicht und so wenn ihr mit dem zusammen
aber wird es ganz alleine geflucht und
ich bin hier glücklich und es wird mit
so passieren wie gottes wort und
überbrücken
[Musik]
wie geht's euch beiden aber das war zu
langsam
[Musik]
bliebe
vor dem berner münster erscheint nun
auch der bräutigam
nachdem dem jungen paar die trauung in
der tamilischen kirche verwehrt worden
war mussten sie sich auf die suche nach
einem fahrer machen der sie trauen würde
nachdem er in ellerhoop fotos habe ich
mir nachbar
[Musik]
rea und babin schilderten der
münsterpfarrer ihre situation und
schnell war diesem klar dass er den
beiden den segen erteilen wollte
[Musik]
liebes hochzeitspaar liebe
hochzeitsgäste er zu bekommen hier
realisiert barbie ihr habt euch gefunden
ihr seid gekommen weil wir miteinander
leben und füreinander da sein wollte
heute wollen ihren gottes segen für ein
gemeinsames leben
wie hatte doch mit gewissen widerständen
zu kämpfen
vielleicht dass es für manche ein
problem dass ein hindu eine kristic
leben
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß nur dass sich
die beiden gern haben und wann dienen
nicht unnötig steine in den weg legen
sollte gott ist nicht christ nicht
hindern nicht jude nicht moslem auch
nicht gut ist oder etwas anderes mit
hilfe der persönlichen worte des
pfarrers überwinden real ira wie und bat
ihn zu entwirren auch dieses hindernis
währungspaar wien die seit heute ja
zueinander und akzeptiert durch
gegenseitig mit ihren stärken und
schwächen wenn ihr den hellen und
glücklichen momenten in dunklen und
traurigen zeiten zu einer bestehen wollt
dann sagt gemeinsam
ja ja
gast
und kaum getraut trauen sie sich
ein kuss vor aller leute augen der
vielleicht mehr bedeutet als mancher
kurz zuvor
denn wie heißt es in der berühmtesten
aller liebesgeschichten kein steinern
bollwerk kann der liebe wehren und liebe
wagt was irgend liebe kann
washington will
euro
[Musik]
[Applaus]